public is a consummate professional and
I think we had every confidence in his
ability to act within the movie
regardless of what's going on in any
aspect of his personal life I would say
probably
um for everyone else it's a good outcome
in the sense that we feel that justice
has been served a lot of people as you
know look at the completion of this film
and view it as disrespectful insulting
even to Helena's memory I know that you
feel differently to that so we've had a
lot of conversations about this and
because her husband and family are on
board with the production and her
husband Matthew Hutchins is an executive
producer on this film we are convinced
that we are doing what she wanted what
her family wants and we're not really
concerned about the broader public and
for Helena's art not to be seen I think
would be a much bigger disrespect